winning a national cheer Association
Championship a national title it's a
major achievement yes a huge
accomplishment this weekend Las Vegas
Segway Ravens are getting a little bit
closer to that goal but they need some
help raising money first Candice Charles
joining us live from sedway middle
school it's in North Las Vegas and you
woke them up very early this morning
Candace
well actually Heather they were already
here they didn't sleep in they were very
excited about this they tried to raise
some money yesterday so they're getting
closer to their goals but they need you
guys good morning YouTube good morning
folks I'm joined by the co-captains
right now Tatiana Whitaker thank you so
much for joining me okay it's about 95
bucks just to go to the competition but
they also need to get food they need to
get hotels they need to get a charter
still and that's going to be a couple of
extra hundred dollars so tell me Tatiana
how it's fundraising been going
fundraising has been going great and I
love the amount of opportunities it's
given us and I appreciate everybody
that's been helping out oh that's very
sweet they're such wonderful young
ladies that have a night here with me
tell us how excited you guys about going
to a competition every single one of us
are very excited and grateful that we're
even able to go to this conversation
we've been working very hard and we're
really grateful for everything awesome
that's okay I know you guys have been
working hard so we're going to give you
guys a little bit of a sneak peek
because we always got you covered with
the fun ladies take it away please
forever
all right if we're at home let's cheer
him on because I definitely still need
your help I'm sure you saw that QR code
you can use it to donate to these ladies
and help them get going oh my gosh
aren't they amazing thank you so much
Team all right this morning's only
getting started you guys can go to our
website newsnow.com to donate coming up
hear a little bit more about the next
competitions they're going to and how
they're still raising money for those
and get to see me cheer of course guys
hang on Candace did you say you that the
kids spent the night at school
I did yes I did say that because they
actually had a huge event here yesterday
they had a couple of dance teams people
came out and donated money they actually
raised about 600 but like I said they
still need to get a charter bus so
they're trying to raise a lot more money
hundreds of dollars still to get that
charter bus so they slept in to get up
early with us and hopefully raise some
more money you guys that's how important
this is to them it really is that's
awesome we want to see them go all the
way thank you so much Candace thank you